接着聊聊咱们正在小歇吧
其实很多事情真的很简单
我们很多人是被自己卡着
就递步
就把自己个下手了
给大家分享一个特别小的故事
你可以去尝试一下
华大师兄
好好的回想
回顾一下
自己曾经做过什么事
哪些事是自己经过困难
然后把他解决的
然后把他一点一点点出来
走到自己上场
这个钱是怎么赚呢
你上场的
别人需要我的中间
那个
就是共同的那个部分
交接的那个部分
就是你赚钱的这个点
我上场的有用
对别人有用
这个钱就来了
那怎么活的用户呢
非常简单的方法
就是好好总结一下
自己当时怎么就有问题的
总结经验和教训
然后想想
还能把他用在什么地方
这个真正赚钱的点在哪
就是很多知识
在你原来那个领域是不知简单的
你换一个领域就知显了
给大家几个小利子
多一钱是成学员
水平呢
中两天上嘛
你不成唱
如果唇靠技术
我可能一年有这个技术案吧
然后呢
后来有一个偶然的机会
先说一下
我当时都不知道
我往上走
还怎么还能怎么走
因为我的知识也就到那个水平了
后来有一个偶然的机会
到广州认识了很多
就是小企业主
就他们就知道了
知道了
做到製造出个小东西
还有什么破壁料理
鸡鸡什么呢
我那个真正破壁料理鸡
然后呢
我见他的时候
发现他们没网站
我说我帮你做过网站的
你搞成员都知道
那个时候做过网站
多种也是个成员就会做
对吧
我就帮他们做了一个
没当初事
審守的嘛
你也帮忙别人
什么忙人家
对你还不错
你做个网站嘛
顺利店做的该是自由
有人的该是自由嘛
就想当于干你的网站
红东西比所有的已经找到
一搜就能收到
破壁料理搜
就能收到
结果做完了以后
那个网站
真的帮了派来多少钱
年龄的时候破壁了
特别的网站
把他身边的很多房子
就还给我
然后就意义给他们做网站
红东西比较多
员员超过了
我在程序界所沾到的钱
那个时候我突然就明白了
啊
员了我这个记住
在我原来那个人不值钱
因为身边的金融的时候太多了
全都会这个了
对吧
就不值钱嘛
而且还要我竞争云嘛
对不对
叫什么
但是你换一个那帮人都不会
都不知道啊
对吧
你一帮他去做
这个时候就之前了
所以很多时候
各位你想想一样
你千万不要
认为你就是联系
你换个联系是
这个体能千一万以后才转钱
啊
那么怎么活得用户呢
这是互联网时代啊
互联网时代啊
就你发个文章啊
你排个视频啊
是不要我钱的
你不要想流量
对吧
你以前英雄呢
走到大街上发
你能发多少啊
对不对
你排一条视频
写个文章
两三百流量
他也是流量嘛
便宜
把他担不好嘛
而且没什么成本
对吧
所以回顾一些
你过往的这个
行李
看看哪些东西
你曾经结果什么的问题
哪些是你的身长
记住了啊
你不要认为他
你不值钱
换一个联系可能就值钱了
对吧
甚至你都不知道他值钱
别人看到就没他值钱
大概写出来
可能就有人看到
就有一个两个人看到的
那就是
手里的来的
有些时候
你要是
不对外
宣传一下
你都不知道自己有多有久
而你要做的
不过就是
把过去的经历总结一下
看看
你觉得有什么东西
对别人有帮助
写两天文章
排两条视频而已